c'était il ya tout juste soixante
quatorze ans andré avait 5 ans un
dimanche qu'il n'oubliera jamais j'étais
attila quand les allemands sont passés
devant moi le matin tu as rêvé et hop où
sont distribués les différentes pièces
pour envahir la maison immédiatement
d'un seul coup ma soeur par la fenêtre
voilée camion d'allemands qu'arrive qui
s'arrêtent devant la porte
et puis tout de suite envahi la maison 1
pour effectivement recherché ce qu'il
voulait entre autres monsieur dutronc
qu'était un grand responsable de la
résistance du secteur elysées spadone
épaules dutronc deux maquisards caché
dans la ferme des guillaume par le père
d'andré lui aussi engagé dans la lutte
contre l'occupant un père heureusement
absents ce matin là et qui venait d'être
dénoncé par d'autres français ils ont
bien essayé de se cacher en sautant
d'une fenêtre d'agen chambly qui étaient
près de la maison pour que ça dure on ne
sait pas combien de temps sauf que quand
qu'il soit arrivé à l'orée du bois
les allemands étaient là ce jour-là paul
dutronc perdra la vie sous les balles
allemandes et son ami déportés 90
soldats allemands renseigner sur une
cache d'armes parachutées par les alliés
quelques temps plus tôt et ne partiez le
temps des deux colis c'est parce qu'elle
n'est même pas que ça pouvait ce qu'on
dit c'est idiot tours à fond chez vous
n'allez c'est comme ça ce jour là les
sections de la wehrmacht poursuivront
leur horrible besogne dans le secteur du
russey un dimanche qu' au total coûtera
la vie de cinq personnes ce 18 juin dans
le haut doubs